positions got to step it up now  oh  all broken up nicely  here comes topping top and back out  barrett barrett a corner three puts it  in rj barrett from downtown he's got  22. watching keep his head up well this  is a steal by the next topping  and watch uh rj  veers to the corner with the three ball  the pelicans right now on a 9-0 run  nick's led by as many as 12 here barrett  three-pointer bang rj barrett with a  clutch straight and the lead back up to  five he's only six foot  five thousand gibson yeah this is barry  big time three ball by varrick  into the hands right back to barrett  barrett has done it all he had a three  ball then he found gibson off the  balance puts it in r.j barrett bucket  after bucket  timeout pelicans as the next go back up  by seven  right now he's tied his career high with  32 dramatic emphatic play by  rj